Alright guys, so this is an example for a short position, so as you can see, we got the ALEG, right? So let me mark this out very easily, there you go. We got the ALEG, we got the B-leg and then we got the C-leg. Perfect. So let me mark this out. So we got the ALEG, right around here, which is from here. Okay. And then we got the B-leg, okay.
is the leg, this downward move.
So we want to mark out the very low of the b leg, which is this.
And we want to mark out the high of the a leg, which is this.
Perfect.
Now the c leg, which is this, it takes out the high of the a leg.
So the high of the L-E leg is here.
L-E like high.
Right?
Let me do this.
Looks better.
There you go.
So the C-E legs takes up the high of the L-E
while leaving some structure here.
So before price took out this high,
it created some structure.
Okay.
Then when price took out the high,
it made a market structure shift.
So it broke this structure, right?
Then price left the imbalance and auto block.
So this is an auto block, right?
We would enter straight from the autoblock, put our stop close right about there, and target
the low, which is here.
So that's 5.62 guys.